E.
I computer quantistici sono molto sensibili al rumore,
disturbi che causano errori
nei loro calcoli, ma una nuova ricerca dimostra
che i computer rumorosi di IBM eguagliano i metodi classici esatti
e verificano i regimi, superando i sofisticati metodi classici
di approssimazione sia nei regimi verificabili
che in quelli non verificabili
per un impegnativo esperimento di simulazione.
Come ci riescono? Usano una tecnica speciale
per gestire il rumore
nei sistemi quantistici: si chiama error mitigation.
Con la tecnica di error mitigation
usata in questo esperimento, eseguiamo i nostri calcoli
aumentando gradualmente il rumore.
Poi estrapoliamo di nuovo fino all'assenza di rumore.
Questo lavoro ci avvicina un passo in più al quantum computing utile
noi